[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and after the
Netflix Marvel shows were sadly canceled
across the board earlier this year we
have new reports that Disney and Marvel
Studios are looking to resurrect the
properties and bring them into the MCU
this report is slowly moving across the
internet and according to sources Marvel
are very interested in bringing Vincent
d'Onofrio's kingpin as well as Charlie
Cox's daredevil into the fold
the latter is rumored to be appearing as
Peter Parker's lawyer in the upcoming
film spider-man 3 and this makes a lot
of sense as the webhead will definitely
need a public defendant at Southside it
will also give someone for she-hulk to
go to for advice down the line and these
two lawyers could add another dimension
to the MCU after the popularity of
daredevil on Netflix this isn't really
surprising and whilst I do think that
the property definitely did diminish
over time these two actors completely
knocked it out of the park with their
betrayals so it makes sense to bring
them to the movies there are rumors that
the show's will be resurrected on Hulu
which Disney now owns and their return
could definitely be set up in the Marvel
films before being fully fleshed out on
smaller screens we know that this is
already happening on Disney plus with
the MCU characters so it makes sense for
the more adult incarnations to take
place on Hulu Vincent D'Onofrio was of
course very vocal about the cancellation
of daredevil and I think the majority of
fans were disappointed by the fact that
we wouldn't really get closure to the
epic season 3 finale did not free OHS
kingpin is arguably up there with Dan oz
as the universe is strongest film and it
would be awesome to see his incarnation
continue to dominate New York many fans
will instantly be on board with the
return to form for the seasons and to
have them feature in the Cinematic
Universe as a reintroduction will
definitely work for a number of big
reasons it just makes sense from a
business perspective to flesh out the
universe even further with the Netflix
universe but to correctly tie them and
be on lip service this time now when
this gets officially announced we will
of course keep you up to date but in the
meantime I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the news and if this has got you
excited for what the future holds
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please like it and
make
check out our breakdown of the sony
disney deal which will be linked at the
end we go over everything you need to
know about the terms and conditions so
make sure that you check it out after
this if you want to know more if you
want to come chat to me about movies TV
shows games and comic books and make
sure you follow me on twitter at
definition white team it's the best
place to get in touch with me and is the
perfect way to suggest new videos and
topics so hopefully I see over there
after this this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like kids
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]